Like you don't need to have all of these
things,
but you better have most of them.
Family,
friends,
career,
educational goals,
plans for old time outside of work.
I attention to your mental and physical
health,
etc. You know those are,
that's what life is about.
10.
If You don't have any of those things,
well then all you've got left is misery
and suffering.
So that's,
that's a bad,
that's a bad deal for you.
So,
so once you,
once you set up that goal structure,
let's say,
and that's really in many in many ways,
that's what you should be doing at
universities is,
that's exactly what you should be doing
is trying to figure out who it is that
you're trying to be.
Right?
And you aim at that and then use
everything you learned as a means of
building that person that you want to
be.
And,
and I really mean want to be.
I don't mean should be even those
things.
Those things are going to overlap.
And it's important to distinguish
between those because that's partly,
and this is back down to the micro
routine analysis.
So I started saying,
well,
you're going to try to make yourself
more industrious.
Okay?
Number one,
specify your damn goals because how are
you going to hit something if you don't
know what it is that isn't going to
happen?
And often people won't specify their
goals too because they don't like to
specify conditions for failure.
So if you keep yourself all vague and
foggy,
which is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well,
then you don't know when you fail.
And people might say,
well,
I really don't want to know when I fail
because that's painful,
so I'll keep myself blind about when I
fail.
That's fine,
except you'll fail all the time.
Then you just won't know it until you
failed so badly that you're done.
And that can easIly happen by the time
you're 40.
So.
So I would recommend that you don't let
that happen.
So that's willful blindness,
right?
You could have known,
but you chose not to.
Okay?
So once you get your goal structure set
up,
you think,
okay,
if I could have this life looks like
that might be worth living despite the
fact that it's going to be,
you know,
anxiety provoking and threatening and
there's going to be some suffering and
loss involved in all of that.
Obviously the goal is to have a vision
for your life such that all things
considered that justifies your effort.
Okay,
so then what do you do?
Well then then you turn down to the
micro routines like,
okay,
well this is what I'm aiming for.
How does that instantiates itself day to
day,
week to week,
month to month.
And that's where something like a
schedule can be unbelievably useful.
google calendar,
it's like naked damn schedule and stick
to it.
Okay,
so what's the rule with the schedule?
It's not a bloody prison.
That's the first thing that people do
wrong.
He said,
well,
I don't like to follow a schedule.
And it's like,
well,
what kind of schedule are you setting
up?
Well I,
I have to do this,
then I have to do this,
you know?
And then I just go play video games
because who wants to do all these things
that I have to do?
It's like wrong.
Set the damn schedule up so that you
have the day you want.
That's the trick.
It's like,
okay,
I've got tomorrow.
If I was going to set it up so it was
the best possible day I could have
practically speaking,
what would it look like?
Well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense,
one of the things that you're gonna
insist upon is that at the end of the
day,
you're not in worse shape than you were
then at the beginning of the day,
right?
Because that's a stupid day.
If you have a bunch of thoSe in a row,
you just dig,
dig yourself a hole,
and then you bury yourself in.
It's like,
sorry,
that's just not a good strategy.
It's a bad strategy.
So maybe 20 percent of your day has to
be responsibility and obligation,
or maybe it's more than that,
depending on how far behind you are.
But even that you can,
you can ask yourself,
okay,
well I've got these responsibilities,
I have to schedule the damn things in.
What's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward?
And you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you.
It'S like,
okay,
you got to work tomorrow.
Okay,
so I want you to work tomorrow.
And you might say,
okay,
well what are you going to do for me
that makes it likely that I'll work for
you while you could ask yourself that,
you know,
maybe you do an hour of,
of responsibility and then you play a
video game for 15 minutes.
I don't know,
whatever turns your crank man.
But you know,
you have to negotiate with yourself and
not tyrannized yourself like you're
negotiating with someone that you care
for that you would like to be productive
and have a good life.
And,
and that's how you make the schedule.
It's like.
And then you look at the day and you
think,
well,
if I had that day,
that'd be good.
Great.
You know,
and you,
you're useless and horrible.
So you'll probably only hit it with
about 70 percent accuracy,
but that beats the hell out of zero,
right?
And if you hit it even with 50 percent
accuracy,
another rule is well,
aim for 51 percent the next week or 50
and a half percent for god's sake or
because you're going to hit that
position where things start to loop back
positively in spiral you upward and so,
so that's one way that you can work on
your conscientiousness is a plan a life
you'd like to have and and you do that
partly by referring to social norms.
That's more or less rescuing your father
from the belly of the whale,
but the other way you do that is by
having a little conversation with
yourself about as if you don't really
know who you are because you know what
you're like.
You won't do what you're told.
You won't do what you tell yourself to
do.
You must have noticed that.
It's like you're a bad employee and a
worse boss,
and in both of those work for you,
you don't know what you want to do.
And then when you tell yourself what to
do,
you don't do it anyways,
you should fire yourself and find
someone else to be.
But,
but you know what my point is,
is that you have to understand that
you're not your own servant,
so to speak.
you're someone that you have to
negotiate with and that's.
And you're someone that you want to
present the opportunity of having a good
life too.
And that's hard for people because they
don't like themselves very much.
So you know,
they're always like cracking the whip
and then procrastinating and cracking
the whip and then procrastinating.
And it's like,
god,
it's so boring and such a pathetic way
of spending your time.
And you know what that's like because
you probably wasted like six hours a
day.
And I think we did an economic
calculation about that a while back,
right?
Your time is probably worth 50 bucks an
hour.
Something like that.
I mean,
you're not getting paid that now,
but you're young.
And so this is investment time and what
you do now is going to multiply its
effects in the future.
So,
so let's say it's 50 bucks an hour,
which is perfectly reasonable.
So if you waste six hours a day and you
are,
then you're wasting about $2,000 a week
or about $100,000 a year.
So like go ahead.
But that's what it's costing you every
hour and you need to know what your damn
time is worth.
So let's say it's not 50 bucks,
it's 30 whatever.
Maybe it's 100,
it's somewhere in that range.
One of the things you should be asking
yourself is when you spend an hour was
that,
well,
what have I paid someone 50 bucks to
have had that hour?
And if the answer is no,
it's like well maybe you should do
something else with your time.
And it depends on whether or not you
think that your time is worthwhile.
But the funny thing about not assuming
that is if you assume your time isn't
worthwhile,
what happens is you don't just sit
around sort of randomly in a state of
responsibility list bliss.
What you do is you suffer existentially.
And so that seems like a stupid
solutions.
You know,
if you take people,
and I've told you this,
and you expose them voluntarily to
things that they are avoiding and are
afraid of,
you know,
that they know they need to overcome in
order to meet their goals,
their self defined goals.
If you can teach people to stand up in
the face of the things they're afraid
of,
they get stronger and you don't know
what the upper limits to that art
because you might ask yourself like if
for 10 years if you didn't avoid doing
what you knew you needed to do by the
deaf,
by your own definitions,
right?
Within the value structure that you've
created,
to the degree that you've done that,
what would you be like?
Well,
you know,
there are remarkable people who come
into the world from time to time and
there are people who do find out over
decades long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were.
if they said if they spoke their being
forward and they get stronger and
stronger and stronger and we don't know
the limits to that.
We do not know the limits to that.
And so you could say,
well,
in part perhaps the reason that you're
suffering unbearably can be left at your
feet because you're not everything you
couldn't be and you know it.
And of course that's a terrible thing to
admit and it's a terrible thing to
consider,
but there's real promise in it,
right?
Because it means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could act in the
world.
So what it would reflect back to you,
it'd be much better than what it
reflects back to you now.
And then the second part of that is,
well,
imagine that many people did that
because we've done a lot as human
beings.
We've done a lot of remarkable things.
And I told you alReady,
I think before the today for example,
about 250,000 people will be lifted out
of abject poverty.
And about 300,000 people attached to the
electrical power grid we're making.
People were lifting people out of
collectively at a faster rate that's
ever occurred in the history of
humankind by a huge margin.
And that's been going on unbelievably
quickly since the year 2000,
the un and plan to have poverty between
2000 and 2015 and it was accomplished by
2030.
So there's inequality developing in many
places and you hear lots of political
agitation about that.
But overall the tide is lifting everyone
up and that's a great thing.
We have no idea how fast we can multiply
that if people got their act together
and really aimed at it.
Because you know,
my,
my experience is with people that were
probably running at about 51 percent of
our capacity.
Something mean you can think about this
yourselves.
I often ask undergraduates how many
hours a day you waste or how many hours
a week you waste.
The classic answer is something like
four to six hours a day,
you know,
inefficient studying,
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch,
that you don't even care about that make
you feel horrible about watching.
After you're done,
that's probably four hours right there.
Now you think,
well that's 20,
25 hours a week.
It's 100 hours a month,
that's two and a half full work weeks.
It's half a year of work weeks per year,
and if your time is worth $20 an hour,
which is a radical underestimate.
It's probably more like 50.
If you think about it in terms of
deferred wages,
if you're wasting 20 hours a week,
you're wasting $50,000 a year and you
are doing that right now and it's
because you're young wasting $50,000 a
year as a way bigger catastrophe than it
would be for me to waste it because I'm
not going to last nearly as long and so
if your life isn't everything,
it could be.
You could ask yourself,
well,
what would happen if you just stopped
wasting the opportunities that are in
front of you?
You be who knows how much more
efficient,
10 times more efficient,
20 times more efficient.
ThAt's the prieto distribution.
You have no idea how efficient,
efficient people get.
It's completely off the charts.
Well,
and if we all got our act together
collectively and stopped making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time.
not only do they not do what they should
to make things better,
they actively attempt to make things
worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
homicidal or genocidal or all of those
things all bundled together in an
absolutely pathological package.
If people stopped really,
really trying just to make things worse,
we have no idea how much better they
would get just because of that.
So there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability,
social judgment,
both of which are are,
are,
are major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt.
And that's the thing that's interesting
too,
is that like one of the another thing
I've often asked my undergraduate
classes,
you know,
there's this idea that,
that people have that people have a
conscience and you know what the
conscience is.
It's,
it's this feeling or voice you have in
your head just before you do something
that you know is stupid,
telling you that probably you shouldn't
do that stupid thing.
You don't have to listen to it strangely
enough,
but you go ahead and do it anyways,
and then of course exactly what the
conscience told you was going to happen
inevitably happens so that you feel even
stupider about it than you would if it
happened by accident because you know,
I knew this was going to happen.
I got a warning it was going to happen
and I went and did it anyways.
And the funny thing too is that that
conscience operates within people and we
really don't understand what the hell
that is.
So you might say,
well,
what would happen if you abided by your
conscience for five years or for 10
years?
What sort of position might you be in?
What sort of family might you have?
What sort of relationship might you be
able to forge?
And you can be bloody sure that a
relationship that's forged on the basis
of who you actually are is going to be a
lot stronger and more welcome than one
that's forged on the basis of who you
aren't.
Now,
of course,
thAt means that the person you're with
has to deal with the full force of you
in all your ability and your
catastrophe,
and that's a very,
very dIfficult thing to negotiate,
but if you do negotiate it well,
at least you have something,
you have somewhere solid to stand and
you have somewhere to live.
You have a real life and it's a great
basis upon which to bring children into
the world,
for example,
because you can have an actual
relationship with them instead of
torturing them half to death,
which is what happens in a tremendous,
a tremendously large minority of cases.
Well,
it's more than that too because,
and this is what I'll close with and
this is why I wanted to introduce social
nixon's readings to you.
You see,
because It isn't merely that your fate
depends on whether or not you get your
act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being.
It isn't only your fate,
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with.
And so you know,
you think,
well,
there's 9 billion,
7 billion people in the world,
we're going to peak at about $9 million
by the way,
and then it'll decline rapidly,
but 7 billion people in the world and
who are you?
You're just one little dust mote among
that 7 billion.
And so it really doesn't matter what you
do or don't do,
but that's simply not the case.
It's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network,
you're a node in a network.
Of course that's even more true now that
we have social media,
you'll,
you'll know a thousand people at least
over the course of your life and they'll
know a thousand people each and that
puts you one person away from a million
and two persons away from a billion.
And so that's how you're connected and
the things you do,
they're like dropping a stone in a pond.
The ripples move outward and they effect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend.
And it means that the things that you do
and that you don't do are far more
important than you think.
And so if you act that way,
of course,
the terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do.
And you might say,
well,
that's better than living a meaningless
existence.
It's better for it to matter.
But I mean if you really asked yourself,
would you be so sure if you had the
choice,
I can live with no responsibility
whatsoever.
The price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters,
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that.
It's not so obvious to me thAt people
would take the meaningful path.
Now when you say,
well,
nihilists suffer dreadfully because
there's no meaning in their life and
needs still suffer.
Yeah,
but the advantages,
they have no responsibility.
So that's the payoff.
And I actually think that's the
motivation.
Say,
well,
I can't help being nihilistic.
All my belief systems have collapsed.
It's like,
yeah,
maybe.
Maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out.
And the price you pay is a meaningless
suffering,
but you can always whine about that and
people will feel sorry for you and you
have the option of taking the pathway of
the martyr,
so that's a pretty good deal.
All things considered,
especially when they are,
when the alternative is to bear your
burden properly and to live forthrightly
in the world.
Well what units and figured out and so
many people in the 20th century,
it's not just him,
even though he's the best example,
is that if you live a pathological life,
you pathologize your society and if
enough people do that,
then it's hell really,
really,
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly,
if it's a light,
if it's a place you'd like to visit and
take all your family and friends because
that's what happened in the 20th
century.
How to think about motivation will think
about it from the hypothalamic
perspective.
So we could say one thing that
motivation does is set goals.
We can say that emotions track progress
towards goals,
and I'm going to use that schema even
though it's not exactly right.
so you say,
well,
motivation determines where you're going
to aim.
So if you're hungry,
you're going to aim at something to eat
and then that will organize your
perceptions so that you zero out
everything that isn't relevant to that
task,
which is almost everything.
You concentrate on those few things that
are going to facilitate your movement
forward.
When you encounter those things that
produces positive emotion,
as you move through the world towards
your goal and you see that things are
laying themselves out that facilitate
your movement forward,
those things cause positive emotion and
if you encounter anything that gets in
the way,
then that produces negative emotion and
it can be like threat because you're not
supposed to encounter something that
gets in the way.
It can be anger so that you move it
away.
It can be frustration,
disappointment,
grief.
Those would,
if,
if you had a response that serious to an
obstacle,
it would probably punish the little
motivated frame right out of existence,
you know,
so you walked downstairs and out.
I know they're contracting company
instead of wrecking ball through your
kitchen.
It's like that's going to be
disappointing.
You're not going to keep eating the
peanut butter sandwich and the rubble,
that little frame is going to get
punished out of existence and some new
goal is going to pop up and instead,
and you know,
one of the things we're going to try to
sort out is how do you decide when
you've encountered an obstacle that's so
big that you should just quit and go do
something else because that's not
obvious,
you know,
and you can,
you can get into counter productive
persistence pretty easily.
So we don't know how people solve that
problem.
It's a really complicated one.
So anyways,
we're gonna work on that scenario.
Your hypothalamus pops up micro goals
that are directly relevant to biological
survival that produces a frame of
reference.
So it's not a goal,
it's not a drive and it's not a
collection of behaviors.
It's a little personality and the
personality has a viewpoint.
It has thoughts that go along with it.
It has perceptions,
it has action tendencies,
all of that.
You can see this in addiction most
particularly,
so one of the things that you find often
with people who are alcoholic is they
lie all the time and that's because when
they're.
They built a little alcohol dependent
personality inside of themselves or a
big one might.
Maybe it's 90 percent of their
personality and one of that.
One of the things that component
consists of is all the rationalizations
that they've used over the years to
justify their addiction to themselves
and to other people and so the addiction
has a personality,
you know,
and so when the person is off or maybe
they're addicted to meth or something
like that,
where we know the addiction is more.
It's more short term powerful than I
would say,
than an alcohol addiction.
They'll say anything and the the,
the words are just tools used to get
towards the goal and if they happen to
be deceptive,
whatever,
it doesn't matter.
They're just practical tools to get
towards the goal.
And then when you get towards the goal
and you take a nice shot of math or
something like that,
you reinforce all those rationales that
you use to get the drug and then the
next time you're even a better deceiver
and liar.
So okay,
so we're gonna say motivations.
One way of thinking about as they set
goals,
but it's not the right way of thinking
about it.
They produce a whole framework of
interpretation.
And so we're gonna.
Think about that framework of
interpretation.
And then emotions emerged inside of
that.
So that's it.
So the world is framed.
Motivations,
set goals.
You could say the world has to be
framed.
SO motivation sets that frame,
cruise goals,
emotions,
perceptions and actions and inactions
track progress.
So positive emotion says you're moving
forward properly towards your goal.
And if you encounter something you don't
expect,
you stop.
That's anxiety.
It's like,
oh,
we're not where we thought we were.
And so we don't know what to do,
so we should stop because we don't know
where we are,
what we're doing.
Stop frozen.
And then the more powerful negative
emotions like pain they might make you
get out of there.
So emotions forward,
stop,
reverse.
That's your emotions within that
motivated.
So.
And that's another example of how your
mind is embedded in your body.
Your emotions are in like their
offshoots of action tendencies.
That's,
that's the right way to think about it
because action is everything
fundamentally.
So what are some basic motivations?
Most of these are regulated by the
hypothalamus,
by the way,
aNd that that tells you just how
important to control system it is.
The other thing that's useful to know
about the hypothalamus is that it has
projections going up from it that are
like tree trunks and inhibitory
projections coming down there.
They're like grape vines.
So you can kind of control your
hypothalamus as long as it's not on too
much,
but if it's on in any serious way,
it's like it.
It winds.
So partly what you do to stop yourself
from falling under the dominion of your
hypothalamus is to never,
ever be anywhere where it's action is
necessary,
right?
You don't want to go into a biker bar
because you might find yourself in a
situation where panicked.
Defensive aggression is immediately
necessary.
You probably don't want that.
You don't want the panic.
You don't want the terror,
you don't want the frenzied fight.
You don't want any of that.
You don't want to have to run away in
absolute panic,
so you just don't go there.
And then a huge,
a huge part of how we regulate our
emotions is just by never going anywhere
where we have to experience them and so
that has very little to do with internal
inhibitory control and everything to do
with staying where you belong.
The myth of mental illness by thomas sad
as zed,
a s zed,
it's classic.
You should read it if you're interested
in psychology,
read it like it's a class and he
basically said,
most people have problems in living.
They don't have psychological problems.
And so I've experienced,
despite my love for the psychoanalysts,
very frequently what I'm doing as a
therapist is helping people have a life
that would work.
you know,
and you can parameterize that.
It's like you need.
How about some friends that you feel
kind of like that?
How about an intimate relationship with
someone that you can trust that maybe
has a future.
That'd be good.
How about a career that puts you in a
dominance hierarchy somewhere so at
least you've got some possibility of
rising,
some possibility of stabilizing yourself
and their schedule and a routine because
no one can live without a routine.
You just forget that if you guys don't
have a routine,
I would recommend you get one going
because you cannot be mentally healthy
without a routine.
You need to pick a time to get up
whatever time you want,
but pick one and stick to it because
otherwise you disregulate your circadian
rhythms and they regulate your mood and
eat something.
In the morning.
I had lots of clients who have that
anxiety disorders.
I had one client who was literally
starving,
very smart girl.
She.
There's very little that she liked.
She kind of tried to subsist on like
half a cup of rice a day.
She came to me and said,
I have no energy.
I come home.
All I want to do is watch the same movie
over and over.
What?
Like is that weird?
And I thought,
well it depends on how hard you work.
You know,
it's a little weird.
Whatever familiar you're looking for
comfort.
So I did an analysis of her diet.
It's like three quarters of a cup of
rice.
It's like you're starving,
eat something,
you know,
you'll feel better.
So she modified her diet and you're all.
Our anxiety went away and she had some
energy.
It's like,
yeah,
you got to eat.
So schedule.
That's a good thing man.
Your brain will thank you for it.
It will stabilize your nervous system
with a bit of a plan.
That's a good thing.
You need a career.
You need something productive to do with
your time.
You need to regulate your use of drugs
and alcohol.
Most particularly alcohol because that
does even a lot of people
need a family,
like the family,
you have your parents and all that.
It'd be nice if you all got along.
You can work on that.
That's a good thing to work on it and
you know you probably need children.
at some point,
and that's life,
that's what life is,
and if you're missing,
you know,
you may have a good reason to not be
operating on one of those dimensions.
It's not mandatory,
but I can tell you that if you're not
operating reasonably well on four,
I think I mentioned six,
if you're not operating reasonably well
on at least three of them,
there's no way you're going to be
psychologically thriving and that's more
pragmatic in some sense than
psychological,
right?
HumAn beings have a nature.
There's things we need and if we have
them well that's good,
and if we don't have them well then we
feel the lack.
So behaviorists,
behavioral psychologists concentrate a
lot more on that sort of thing.
No,
it's practical.
It's strategizing.
Make a career plan,
figuring out how to negotiate because
that's bloody important.
Figuring out how to say what you need to
figure out how to tell the truth.
He figure out how to listen to your
partner in particular because if you
listen to them,
they will actually tell you what they
want and sometimes you can give it to
them and maybe they'll return the favor
and if you practice that for like 15
years,
well then maybe you're constantly giving
each other what you want.
Well,
hooray.
That would be good.
And then there's two of you under both
circumstances and it's better to have
two brains than one because people think
differently because of their temperament
mostly.
And so the negotiation is where the
wisdom arises and it's part of the
transformation,
a psychological transformation that's
attendant on an intimate relationship
and one the fundamental purposes
of a longterm intimate relationship.